what's the theory behind starting a
second C second at Big Cat of course how
could I how could I
[Music]
[Applause]
forget I have started with calvs for
more than 10 years now uh straight and
the reason for that is because calvs are
my weakest body part uh in terms of like
proportions isn't this nice it's
something it's meant for two it is kind
of cute system it is kind of cute yeah
that's great so I actually train my body
in reverse order of weakness wouldn't
advise it like my reverse order of my
like worst body part to best body part
okay if you go ground up legs Wise It's
like your calves are nice and warm and
then I do hamstrings next yep and so our
knee joint's going to be like nice and
loed up so that when I actually do a leg
move I feel pretty good when I put them
first and then I doubled the amount of
volume and I did them in every workout
rather than like two times a week um
that's when my Cal started to really
grow I think that there's something
definitely underrated about starting a
session with a real low investment
movement it's like no one's ever going
to say no to another set of car phrases
I really don't want to train today yeah
well stand on the edge of this thing
you're actually converting me you're
actually converting me I mean like I've
been doing this for 20 years so like
like i' I've done iterations I've been
doing this for 10 like I haven't I
haven't changed it cuz it's like it's
right I've had say that you do just one
body part each session M and just
consistently get volume in is that still
the same
100% I don't think that many people have
the same approach to training that Alex
does not many people begin their workout
with like a 100 repetitions on Cs and
not many people do the exact same
routine every single session full body
have you ever ever had any temptation to
do a different training modality uh
functional thing in Brazilian Jiu-Jitsu
thing CrossFit thing nope no design none
I did my my experimentation way earlier
like when I was in my like 20s I was
like I'll try CrossFit it I did all body
weight for 6 months I did only swimming
you know what I mean um I did only CLE
Bells I did that per year I didn't know
anything so I started from absolute
ignorance and so I would read these
sales letters for like kettle bells and
I'd be like oh kettle bells are what I
need to do and then I'd read a new ebook
about like how body weight training was
like the new thing and I would just do
body weight stuff and then I'd read
about isometrics is actually where you
can get the most strength and I would do
that and so I I did all sorts of
programs and methodologies uh for a
while before I kind of like actually
learned the few things that matter I
wanted Max
Muscle uh least
headache I train full body every day so
like body composition Wise It's the best
for me I can do supet so I don't have to
do
cardio
oh and you gain the most
muscle so like why would I want anything
that's not the most muscle yep and that
works for me good but hamstrings after
this will feel great yeah cuz your calvs
always get involved in hamstrings so
it's like prefatigue the calvs and then
it'll only be hamstrings yes pref faue
calvs and hams and it'll only be quads
right yep very
nice ham chop you want to do seated or
lying we'll do seated chop
no I would always if I was ever doing
seated hamstring curls I would always
superet them with uh like extensions
always because for me I'm like why
wouldn't I why wouldn't I why wouldn't
you well why wouldn't I cuz then I'll be
out of breath but I thought that the
super sets I thought super sets were
cardio if I was trying to get in better
shape today's not cardio
day in between sets is is is camera time
understood and when camera's not here
it's rest time
why Lean Forward you'll
see so lock it down as much as hard as
you can on your knees like extra there
you go so lean forward and put your
chest up see the stretch now leaning
forward even more
yeah arch your arch your chest more so
the stretch of your hamstring to catch
you there you
go it stretches the out of it like
this and then also keeps tension the
whole time on your hamstring yep so you
don't have any rest whereas if you're
back here right you're now yeah yep it's
way pumpy that way but this made this
like got my hamstring so much better
than leaning back yep Big Stretch big
squeeze Big Stretch big
squeeze multiple gym memberships within
the same city so good because you get
sick of training in one place or you're
in a different vibe kind of the same as
the working thing at the desk change
your environment yeah so if I need to
prep for a guest I go to Gold South
Central it's nice and quiet no one ever
hassles me if you want to get session in
with the boys there's a spit and swust
indoor outdoor thing that's really cool
and then if we want to do some
functional classes on it got a gym
really
[Music]
good good man o ymy
YY
if you really want to with yourself
Point your toes forward now try it oh
that's
awful oh cuz it shows you how much your
cap gets involved yeah you flex your cap
can't use it
yeah it's crazy how many variants there
can be of one movement where you think
I'm totally locked in but then
if I go here and then if I go here but
then if I don't go here totally
different yeah crazy it's actually a
cool mechanical drop set that way so you
start with your toes out yep and then
you basically go neutral EAS yep yep
yep but I usually just go limp feet so
like not this way which still helps you
y this way like which takes it all out I
just go neutral dangly dangly feet
dangly feet I've always preferred
training with a partner I think
especially after a long time in the gym
a decade and a bit you end up just
running out of juice I just don't have
all that much motivation when I'm on my
own I'll go in and I'll go through the
motions but if I'm going to push myself
even remotely hard I need someone else
there or else you end up scrolling Doom
scrolling on your phone or getting
distracted by emails or
something
what yeah
[Music]
boy it's funny cuz people in the gym are
going to think we're Fitness influencers
but we're not all of these videos have
got nothing to do with the
Fitness in fact the fitness is just a
break from recording content yeah
shouldn't they be in better
shape why aren't they
bigger I ask myself that every day why
isn't he wearing a supplement company's
apparel what's he acquiring yeah what is
he
acquiring isn't he acquired any
muscle yeah why you acquire some gains
bro it's like ideally you want to walk
it like right above your kneecap yes and
then it stabilizes the joint
come on
dude
yep all right that's it for me that cool
that
cool this is one of those machines where
three plates could be impossible or
three plates could be absolutely nothing
yeah it'll be between those two extremes
that's my
promise oh feel can you try and touch
your hamstring to your butt
now there's a little bit of rainy SL I
think he's a little puffed up K we tell
you about this so I'm trying to make
puffy a thing yeah yeah I'm all puffed
up oh my legs are all puffed right
now
o how many vest Brands did you need to
go through before you decided on the one
that every acquisition doc thing is
printed on you mean this uh particular
vests yeah tank top okay yeah yeah yeah
um probably 30 or 40 okay yeah what were
the most common problems that you
encountered with other vests if you get
10 mediums and they fit different
there's not consistency there it's one
two they shrink differently where am I
here here and then that out yeah this
turns out and then hands
here different ones shrink at different
uh sizes when you wash yep um some of
them were like too thin up top or too
thick up top yep some of them would
Bunch so it kind of like float like this
above the actual softness of the of the
shirt cuz sometimes it's just like it
just feels like paper so I look for like
softness oh too thick I guess yeah and
then some of them don't stretch at all
so I need a little bit like elastic in
it so it shows all the good hides all
the bad you know what I'm saying um
those are the big I actually have a list
on my phone for like all the things I
was rating them on but those are off the
top of my head
good I'm still not done my shoe test I'm
on like shoe number probably
50 and what is it that you uh a lot
shoes are the toughest by far you think
it has to be able to get me into a nice
establishment yep I have to be able to
work out in it yep it has to be able to
get wet cuz I don't want to have like a
different shoe when I'm traveling that
gets wet y my feet Can't Sweat in it and
they can't smell over time yeah that's
hard and you don't wear socks I don't
wear socks yeah that's difficult I mean
that's a high B just that just that is a
high B yep yep and I be able to work out
with him like doing calf
raises and also like and I have to be
able to walk in them with no like
blisters anywhere yep and I walk an hour
every day are you puffy puffy I'm very
puffy okay good would you be able to get
into a nice establishment in in those
trainers do you think yeah
the only thing I've ever seen at the
nicest places is no sandals it's just
too many Rich guys where yeah normal you
of the red sneaker effect right what uh
there was a study done at a conference
with businessmen and they tried to
quantify the objective metrics of how
smart somebody dressed and there was an
inverse correlation between the
smartness of dress and the net worth or
the job title that this person had so
it's the people who had dressed down the
most that had the most wealth checks out
counter signaling is a hell of a drug
man I mean usually I try and rest as
little as I
can between sets that's the strange
thing about training with a partner even
though you have to wait for someone else
to finish that set yeah you you rest
less you rest less because you've got uh
cuz you're not on your pH timer and the
timer is the other person's set I'm
about 50/50 uh in terms of whether I
train with people or not
uh there are seasons where I like find
somebody that like we have a times that
work out for a season and I work out
with them and then there's times when my
schedule's kind of crazy and I just get
workouts when I can um I would say that
I far prefer working out with other
people whenever I can just because I I
train harder I train longer I do more
sets I probably do better form um and I
and I I just in general work out harder
and longer when I have other people
around me yes like Optimal two to one
yeah I would say that that's probably
not and that's exactly what it is it's
two two parts rest for one part lifting
I would say there's two different types
of training sessions so there's like a
training session where you're like going
in there to die and remove your own soul
and look at it like deep into its own
eyes and then put it back into yourself
um and then there's training sessions
where it's like I would say a more
social training session uh and to me
that was like a more social training
session so I still got a workout in but
like I wasn't dying if you want sneaky
cardio 90 minutes of pickle B is 1,000
calories it's insane and you
don't even think you're just like you're
just chasing a ball you're not doing
cardio you're chasing a ball a, calories
on a concept 2 ski or or something
miserable yeah my dear hell so that goes
to what Trevor was talking about where
the people who are the quote most
disciplined aren't actually more
disciplined they figure out something to
do in the
meantime so it's like you did the same
cardio as the guy on the ski he gets off
he's like I'm so disciplined and
to you it didn't feel like discip yeah
like the opposite right so I think like
their in lines are pretty big find #
find your pickle ball find your pickle
ball and then get puffy on it I I don't
stop trying to make puffy a thing
Puffy's not going to be a thing oh it's
going to be huge big puff Chris and I
have a good Dynamic um on the podcast
and off the podcast I think we um very
bro talk uh so it we keep it light which
is nice because you know life can be
really serious all the time and it's
it's ironic because he has a podcast on
like wisdom and deep philosophical
things and it'd be really easy to take
yourself seriously and I'm glad that he
doesn't and uh and he can talk with
me what say you think we'll do one more
just in
case you know the
rule if you have to ask if you have if
you have another set left you got a do
another set what if you more more ear
you want me to see there yeah because
the machine Mak go up yeah so if your
feet are too much well and up that's
going to push you up so like you go more
wide just like this and more wide you're
going to be more a to fill all this part
made for all right that's what we're
doing little bit more high and more
white too this the corner yeah all right
here yeah o all that doctor yeah all
right open this yeah
yes yeah I see one
[Music]
more
yep
[Music]
hey why you got to listen to Pros baby
the greatest hack of all time whether
it's bodybuilding or business is getting
with people who are far ahead of you um
I mean almost all of the periods of my
life where I had huge changes or
improvements in my physique was when I
had people who were better than me
giving me Insight because the thing is
it's like you can learn a certain amount
but like if someone has a decade of
experience on something and then they
can just immediately spot like even if
you're a video editor someone like oh
dude you missed this you like they they
have more context to give you advice um
and it's invaluable which is why I've
I've tried to buy any experience I can
from anybody who's willing to sell it to
me I'd rather get the lesson without the
scar all right let's
shoulders yeah there nice seated
yes oh yeah the uh post quad stretch for
Max
pump brutal my quads are on fire right
now what's the keys here any oh so do
this right before we start your
shoulders like forward not back forward
so you where do you want to have them
sit as far out as you can yep got you
okay
nice most be a smaller metor and rear
ads so I pretty much just exclusively
train medial and rear not even train
front not my deficiency not my
constraint not my
[Music]
problem
come
on
yep so I would like to enter into your
shoe rotation Van's old school comfy
Kush but I think them today I think they
fail on smell yeah and I think that they
fail on getting wet it depends on how
wet wet From Below fine wet from above
not good so they have a new one that
came out that has cork bottom
and it's mesh on top so it's meshy like
this oh I've seen them they're called
like the move I was wearing them today
underneath the table I didn't no I
didn't notice good so far they they
haven't failed any tests but these are
better to work out in got you slip on
slip off if you've got a shoe horn
shoehorn no you're red pill on shoe horn
no come on you ever have to fight to put
your shoes on these are stretchy but
what about the vans that was a downside
for them I wasn't a Fanon and you
bypassed that's expanded your choice it
has landscape by having a shoe on I
usually only do slip on slip off how
much do you value the skin on the back
of your thumb probably quite highly I
would imagine extremely high yeah
arguably the highest skin most valuable
skin really oh yeah really think about
ah lots of people in America are
circumcised AR they I
forget yeah I'm probably the only person
in this building with a four skin that's
C we'll cut that one from the re just
like he
got
see what it did
there question for you yes who's your
favorite person to interview who's the F
your favorite
interviewer interviewers Rogan the guy
is so good it's all
about people from the outside will see
someone that's got a very successful
platform but his use of cadence and
silence in a conversation
is unbelievable I thought I've worked
very hard at this done 600 episodes I
get to S sit down with this guy and it's
like being a a black belt and going no I
get to roll with the seventh Dan let's
see how good he actually is and you're
like what the was that very very
very impressive like super impressive
interviewer that's cool terms of people
to interview one person that I love
consistently is Rory suland oh okayy
he's so fun super easy very
knowledgeable very knowledgeable um
something about seeing a guy double
fisting Vapes throughout the entire
episode one of which is on a rope around
his neck so he'll have one on a rope
around his neck so it's never more than
a foot and a half from his mouth at any
one time and uh Stills
legendary how's this feel shorer wise
good yeah that's good it's a a quite a
weak angle like you know if you were
here you'd be way way way stronger but
it feels like it's that kind of um given
that you've done 3,500 hours yeah of
writing yeah what are the main
principles that you rely on to remove
friction from the writing process what
are the water desk setup time like well
not everything and in terms of like the
writing got it um I mean I I pretty much
just write the same time every day which
is when I wake up and then I write till
noon and that's basically the only thing
I don't do anything else yep but you're
using I saw you use nicotine today
during the podcast I did that all time
though so that's not equal opportunity
very good je it's task independent yeah
yeah so I guess the lesson from that
nicotine a global reward what's that
it's a global reward you can do you can
use it to reward anything something
tells me that you and Rory are aligned
on
this come
[Music]
on oh cheeky little drop set go on then
yeah cheeky little drop set oh there it
is
get
those so the rule is sit down and write
that's the rule it's not even a rule
that's just like when I do it no but
that's your strategy your strategy is
sit down and write I'll say this my
strategy is do the thing that's most
important first okay and for now it's
writing and then it'll be something else
later yep so that that's my I would say
the macro calendar is the bigger thing I
don't take meetings until noon or 1 and
then that first slot gets switched out
with whatever the priority is yep
understood do you take a break during
writing during that 6- hour block to
have like a shake yep half the time I do
it while I'm writing half the time I
take a break if I need it yep okay but
not long 15 minutes interesting was it
more difficult before you were in the
editing phase in that there's a maximum
number of ideas per minute that you can
put out onto paper so you have to kind
of sit and think what I'm actually
trying to do or say here I say it's more
phases so it was more like figuring out
what I'm going to say first that's what
the longest then was writing it which
took which was the easiest yep and then
basically taking what I wrote cutting
out half of it filling in the other half
cutting half of it again filling in the
next half cut it just basically just
continue to just compact compact compact
compact the book's probably 270 pages
but it got compressed from 1 th000 plus
yep and just like the rule is always
like if we read two sentences is and if
we only read one of them it still meant
the same thing one of them is not
required and we just do that over and
over and over again yep so that my hope
is that the whole book is literally
tweet after tweet after tweet for 300
Pages you read the almanak of Nal rabant
yeah yeah kind of like that right very
dense High signal to
noise this one's going to be a bear cuz
it's basically like eight books in one
which sounds ridiculous to say but like
it shows how to do warm Outreach cold
Outreach post content run ads hire
agencies hire hire recruit train train
manage
employees build uh affiliate programs
build referral
systems in one book and so like each one
of those 25 to 30 pages was probably
like a 150 page relevant book yes that
just got squeezed until there was
nothing left we could cut and it's like
if you read this you will know how to
set up Affiliates if you read this you
know how to set up a referral system if
you read this you know how to get your
first five clients for more rage outs if
you read this you know how to post
content to get customers was there
anything that you had to write that you
didn't know um yeah all the time I have
like my best ideas of like this it's
usually I start with anecdote of like
this is what we did this is what worked
well and then that's what Trevor and I
will beat up until we're like what are
the principles behind a good referral
system and then one doesn't and then
we'll try and break it and be like all
right was the one that worked that
didn't have those things and we just
that process is what takes the longest
yep because we want it to be valid yep
and that's the hard part yes cuz it's
very like every marketer has their
system in their head and they write it
down and they send it but you can
immediately break it which is why it's
not valid which is why it doesn't get
shared why it doesn't become Canon so
the goal was like if I can make
something that no one can disprove then
they become Canon and people can use it
so first one was offers yep second one's
leads leads third one is fourth one
is I have a couple ideas but for now the
next book cool there'll be more yep all
right um last set one more all right if
you have to ask all right we'll do um
we'll do a double drop okay so go 10 10
10 cool all right yeah I think that was
what I was trying to get at today with
that bridge between the philosophy and
the applicability yeah and that because
in the world of business a great
philosophy that doesn't make money
doesn't matter doesn't matter yeah the
validity of the model is how much money
you make correct right which means that
a beautifully sounding theory that isn't
effective in the real world is pointless
ah so everything that you're talking
about has being stress
tested well we just start with what
worked and then we try and figure out
what makes it work always
yeah so it's like Affiliates we're like
how much do we pay them on what
Cadence and do we have tears and what do
they have to do to earn the tears yep
how do we activate them how do we get
them to keep
marketing
[Music]
so this will just bother all the fitness
people but I try and do as many perfect
reps as I can and then I try and do as
many imperfect reps as I
can and people are like isn't that going
to only strengthen a certain range how I
see it is I fatigue all the stuff that I
can at max range and then I keep going
until I fatigue the stuff I can do
partial range so just for me it kills it
more and I get more volume in per set
I'm definitely not an expert but for me
once I'm here this is the end of my delt
as I feel it everything above that for
me is trap and I get these crazy pains
in my neck so I have a nice stop sign CU
I feel a shooting pain but for me I can
just do this and know that that's the
end of my delt and so that's the range I
train but plenty of people disagree with
me and they're probably rip and smarter
I think it was I think this was like
when I was training classes at
Huntington Beach this was a hot song so
I heard it like 40 times a day I'm sure
when you were clubbing there's just
songs like umbrella correct right
correct given that I listen mostly to
either like British rap or metal neither
of which get played in nightclubs all
that much I knew the words to every
single song that was in the top 40 for a
decade and a half what of metal all
sorts dude Bring Me The Horizon what
about hard or dad metal what hard or dad
metal Dad no not Dad metal give me a
break this one arm yeah one arm yep I
trying to lean my hip out so you get a
bigger stretch you'll see are you on
under yeah I'm under under here here
here yeah and then just wedge yourself
yeah you know you asked me earlier about
do I remember this name of the song that
was playing yeah I don't know the name
of any song Like lyrics for sure it's
kind of a crazy claim I don't know the
name of any song I'll say it this way
like me recognizing a song by
name is very hard for me and I listen to
that for what do you think that says
about you I have very bad audio memory
my wife will attest to
that wouldn't it be great if you have
absolutely great audio memory and
forgetting all of these song names it's
just one long
troll really bought in keep saying
forgets the name of Rihanna the only
song that I know the full lyrics to was
one that I had to write out in seventh
grade they were trying to teach poetry
and they're basically saying look songs
are poems like you know whatever and so
I remember the eve6 song that I wrote
down and that was it and there was like
you had to find similes and metaphors
like in the in the thing wow
that's it this the only one I know the
lyrics though cuz I I could read it
funny come
[Music]
on there you
go I actually
think that this bag is a very good
physical
representation of your life
philosophy I think it's incredibly
transactional it's like just does the
thing even if it's not what it was
designed for it actually does it better
than something else might do it again
just stinks of horoi doesn't it
absolutely reeks of
horoi um zero
Aesthetics uh very
functional uh
odd it completely disregards
convention how many things did you go
through before you tried this oh plenty
yeah different types of bags different
types of setup rolly bag and you settled
on that a workman's bag yeah also lasts
forever but it still had a bunch of
issues with it so I ended up modifying a
bunch uh to the bag like cutting things
off and like moving stuff around um but
what I have now is the best you know gym
bag that I know of and uh it kills yeah
midback smokes
it oh uh other things that I've had to
learn since I've been in America biscuit
uh isn't a biscuit no not a thing
biscuits a cookie for dogs biscuit is
like a scone that goes on the side of
beef yeah at Cracker Barrel yeah piece
of bread yeah Fu a piece of bread chips
or it's a dog biscuit in which case it's
a treat for a dog fine yeah chips me
like thick french fries yeah they're not
no very difficult assimilating into this
new culture has been incredibly
difficult for me and I spent Fourth of
July here which was emotionally quite a
tough day yeah anyone comment uh I wore
a t-shirt that said uh happy treas and
day ungrateful colonists yeah yeah
um was it and then people were like
winers right history
do you see any backtack world war
Champs no that's
funny yep
[Music]
yep oh yeah oh that smokes is one of the
problems of training with Alex somebody
who has a very dialed in gym routine
that for him he doesn't train his chest
doesn't train his chest because he says
his chest doesn't need to grow
anymore
some of us don't have that problem might
have been nice to done some chest today
but look and I'm in his
town for the back
titties the back titties it's a big back
back puff big back puff oh stop trying
to make puff
happen Puffy's going to be
huge stay puffy all right
make sure that chap sticks nice and
secure in case something traumatic
happens during these Bice that's the
that's my sunstream that oh see
interesting yeah and here look you see
the pocket for it on the side oh no
meant for it it's meant to be all
right so I just move them forward like 2
in and then you get the full stretch
yeah it's just significantly harder and
you get a mean Pump am I doing it
right doesn't give a he's busy it's
like I'm busy being bigger than busy
being
massive am I doing
it
Sor come
on here
yeah yeah right
there tight did before you go fight
up woo
spicy very
spicy
that's right kale who's bigger am I
bigger am I bigger I don't
know I don't think I get my leg
up they have good legs Bo just because
normally you have more water on the L
Body theer more what you have more water
the
theer don't
[Laughter]
do
all right so how do you how do you not
stay egotistical if people
bigger than
you I feel like that's like a perfect
microcosm of what we're talking about
yep corre correct
[Music]
correct come on just catches up come on
come
on oh
yeah 20 lbs never felt so
heavy
it oh yeah humbling oh
yeah it's just not heavy enough at that
cuz like you can do adult raise with 20
so like this angle it's like not that
bad there you go back
more there it is money
reps okay
yep must be
nice
like I live for the day when fashion has
developed enough for guys that I just
need to wear a single piece of material
in the gym I I hardcore considered it
overalls cuz then it would like
eliminate so many things from my life I
mean if you if you
had I kill
the only thing so I'd have to find what
do you call the uh the girl version of
that a romper yeah it' have to be a jean
Romper cuz I want the short version I
don't want the I get
hot I give a go Lea would probably
Revolt but I would continue anyways
because she's more attracted to the fact
and I what she thinks that's a
really interesting point it's an
interesting point that something that
your wife would prefer you doing is less
attractive than you not doing the thing
that she would prefer you doing because
of what it means to her yes correct
correct just preaching the gospel
here of personal of personal
uh personal brand what we call it
personal identity there you go PR brand
of authenticity it's like the inverse of
the test you know like test so
test was this thing that came up
during pick aarts history that girls
would like give you a a challenge of
some kind or I bet you're not actually
that strong in the gym or I bet you
don't actually have that job I bet you
don't drive whatever the whatever the
thing and that was a test yeah and
it was uh the same way that some female
frogs will uh fight with males to test
their strength before they actually
decide to sleep with them okay and
uh would be like I'm ready this feels
like the reverse of that this is like
she's she's testing you but the actual
outcome that's optimal for attraction is
you you reject her you reject the test
entirely yeah you punk the game yeah cuz
I feel like I was thinking I was like
what would I say if some girl was like
you really don't make what you say you
make I'd be like
okay I just like be like I'm sure you
have somewhere I probably wouldn't even
say that I would just say okay and keep
talking to whoever I was
talking come
on dud I just love these reps they just
feel so
good come
[Music]
on
oh yeah there it is big
squeeze the largest squeeze dude I'm
getting puppy I can feel
it my arms are puffed I'm like 3/4
puffed not full puffed this is a public
service announcement Alex stop trying to
make puffy a thing it's never going to
be a thing and it makes me uncomfortable
every time that I hear you say it can't
even push back back against it you're
like what are you pushing back against
I'm like well pushing back against
you're saying that word what word yeah
the p word yeah don't say the p
word there you
go all right let's put these back we'll
do some tryceratops
so fun fact I tweaked the out of my
tricep like two months ago and then
rather than take off I just went to the
lowest weight I could on this machine
because this is the machine I tweaked it
on and then I've just been adding 10 lbs
every week and now I I'm like back and
it doesn't hurt it's the best way I know
how to
rebap keep moving but keep moving light
just basically keep dropping the weight
until it does like whatever the thing
you hurt it on it's kind of like with
gymnast they tell him to get right back
on the pommer horse if you fall off so
you don't like
get up in the head about it so I
hurt myself on this machine and then I
dropped it down to like the lowest thing
I do that didn't hurt and then I just
add it back rather than being like Oh
I'm going take like two months off or
whatever I just came right back and did
the lowest weight I could without it
hurting so you like
this it's a little lad at the top from
that that boy is a little yeah I just
try to maximize whatever the my angle of
the like when to squeeze this it's not
like cuz obviously you could do this
yeah but it'd be weird in my opion
yeah yeah it's more like how can I keep
this
angle as as acute as possible and then
get it a lot of stuff on like warm-ups
is not like super definitive it's like
stretching there's like Bodies of
Evidence on both sides that like doesn't
help prevent injury blah blah blah so
like I think it's more about warming
core temperature rather than like each
specific movement so that's why I do CS
first cuz I get warm another reason I do
CS first the Bulgarian Olympic team
never warmed up they went straight to
squats now it's more Testament to the
fact that they pick the right people who
wouldn't get injured training that way
correct than it is a measure that that
training is effective so here's
something that's interesting a question
that I had for you that's more about how
you guys work with
acquisition. there's a very common
strategy that people use when it comes
to growing a business that's in that
kind of region yeah which is is bring
somebody on board and then apply ungodly
amounts of pressure to the founder just
lean on the founder like and the
presumption is that they're either going
to crush under the pressure and if they
manage to stick about the business by
design has made three years of growth in
one year what do you think about that
approach I think it's actually dictated
by the returns they promis limited
partners more so than it's basically
like we have to deliver these returns in
5 years the only way for that to happen
with a VC model which is usually the
ones that do that are that they have to
spray and prey on 50 Investments knowing
that one's going 100x and cover the
whole portfolio in terms of returns and
they can afford to have lots of losses
so what's different with what you're
doing we don't really think any of them
are going to think any of them are 100x
but it's not the model we don't we're
not like a tech primary investor like
we're much more what I would call
everyday businesses like mortgage sales
photography shops you know what I mean
just normal businesses Insurance
like that and uh for us I would rather
have all of our businesses triple over 5
years get same or better returns than
those guys do and not burn 49
relationships both work financially it's
just also like how you want to live life
and we are
also like we're growth Partners but a
lot of businesses don't require a win or
take all model like Facebook one guy was
going to get the whole social network so
you have to do it that way but like
mortgage sales one guy doesn't like
there's no advantage to you're not going
to take the mortgage sales Market you'll
just keep gnawing away at it and there's
a lot of businesses that if they didn't
have that forced pressure would
otherwise be good businesses even if
they don't have an enormous Tam they can
still generate really good returns not
100x returns but you could get a 10x and
I'd rather take a 10x when I can get it
than force a 100x and lose a 10x you
know in the
process given that you do full body
every day do you cycle different
exercises across the week not a fun do
you do them across
periods I train the same body parts
every day y we did hip thing today if
I'm feeling it I'll do that for a little
bit if I'm not feeling it one day i' do
a different leg
exercise I just don't have a lot of
rules but my point being that given that
you want a well-rounded physique yeah
for instance if you were to continue to
do this you're never actually going to
yeah I use like when I do back my break
Alice gets hit yep and I will without
trying overtime cycle things in and if I
ever identify that I have a weakness
like a clear visual weakness then that
moves up in the workout like I'll I'll
really prioritize otherwise I'm also
kind of at like the point in my care
like I'm not really going to gain any
more muscle so it's just like I
stimulate that keeps what I've got try
not to hurt myself do that hopefully
until I
die that's my perspective how's your dad
built physically uh like me but doesn't
have like yeah yeah muscle muscle but
you think you had a good genetic base
yeah I think um so I was I heard about
this from Greg Knuckles big big lifting
guy some people who are who are
naturally like big and muscular have low
potential for growth but have a high
Baseline yep some guys have huge growth
potential but are tiny dudes genetically
so people see people they're like dude
that guy's a house like if
he actually lifted but they're
completely separate jeans interesting
stay puffy